[Music]
[Music]
see BBS which is a center for bicultural
bilingual studies at MIT has kindly
asked me to introduce Professor Roger to
you this afternoon and and I feel
extremely honored and privileged to do
so so some of you may already have
listened to him last night and and if
you have and have come back it's because
you're you know that you're in for a
treat again and if you have not yet
listened to him and heard him you will
soon find out how fortunate you are to
be here and how fortunate we are okay so
I should speak to us on campus so but
first let me say just a few words about
him now he's an internationally renowned
linguist who was born and raised in
Tunis and ever since he was a child he
told us yesterday he was thrown to
languages and himself speaks I just
asked him how many languages is spoken
to me I don't know how to count them so
anyway at least 10 maybe 12 who knows
but and so he has written many many
books and articles ranging from very
scholarly works to about generative
grammar to works on the origins of
languages as well as the social and
cultural impact of language and all this
being the result of a tireless
combination of theoretical research and
fieldwork
mr. Ellis a judge is a man never tired
tells us and never rests
and since 1988 he has been teaching at
leadership the daily linguistic
organized across and has received many
many awards among which 1995 the bid I
go to you still an MS which is a French
award given to people
we're different only two people what
could you do exceptionally to research
and and it was the number of you here is
also a testament to that as well
plus you will discover and something you
may not get to that mr. Padgett on top
of everything else is that delightfully
it is totally delightful man a widely
played one which is entitled and I
Mowgli longer and which is by the way
about to be translated in English and
published by Stanford University Press
is it is a plate wide year is a call for
action if you will about a wake-up call
about the catastrophic at least his own
world impact the disappearance of
languages has on our overall human
social cultural and
national heritage this topic this
afternoon is English as a global
language threat or myth it's a topic
that no doubt who rouses quite a bit of
interest and in those who feel sometimes
passionately the way the French do
particular that their own language has
been threatened but what is often
perceived as the linguistic cultural
imperialism report of English I say
quote because this is a word that
professional Padgett uses himself and I
hope you don't think it's too polemic
and and in I suspect that this topic
that most of you here are interested in
sister anyway in this book I tell about
the long professor a judge writes and I
quote in French person language Nevada
to achieve the pseudo Monday Suki build
you Connie Longworth la falda jinwu is a
people's not shaking day long it sa
grande popular moment but it's off to
the catastrophic so he surveyed so she
discarded attempted not befool you
neither said humanity feebly translated
says might be useful to ask myself what
is lost when languages died the part of
genius that is deposited with languages
is large enough that when some guy
it can be called catastrophic and that
what disappears is for live forever lost
to our University so it is about this in
the sociable relationship between
language cultural identity and
humanities with that mr. Coolidge
Elizabeth West a bit and within the
framework of the topic is English as a
global language so he will speak for pub
I know I say so much like Azizi speak so
many languages maybe because of this
question yes yes I would reply to any
question asked in Chinese Arabic Russian
Spanish Italian let us say except
English before starting with respect to
the question you asked I did not answer
immediately but I reflected I thought
over your question and now I have a kind
of reply language I speak well so in
order to answer this question and how
many in which I speak I think of my old
rabbi in my childhood he said when
someone who don't know someone who might
be a fish is not your case by any means
asks you a question
he said with a Jewish leader intonation
thanks sir but another question so since
you asked the question I will answer
what do you mean by speaking the
language if you mean how many English do
your rights
do you give talks in do you use to write
books without necessary speak speaking
of them and if you mean how many
languages do you use when you are in
love of someone the answer will vary
according to these different
circumstances
well the title of this talk partly oh
yes I might make me the wrong talk
whether we monitor the routable army of
english-speaking econo Technical
Specialist advisors and Representatives
or whether we examine the diffusion of
English publications films radio and
television programs literacy programs
and educational opportunities it is
becoming increasingly clear that
non-english mother tongue countries are
significantly active in each of these
connections nor is their involvement
merely that of third-world receptions or
Western largesse true third world
nations are themselves fostering massive
efforts via and on behalf of English on
the other hand however equally massive
programs by English are being conducted
by the Soviet Union by the Russians let
us say the Arab world and mainland China
world powers that have their own
well-developed standard languages and
that normally oppose various political
philosophical and economic goals of the
English mother tongue worlds whereas the
International and international rivers
of French also continue to be fasted as
do to a lesser degree such rules for
Spanish Russian German Portuguese and so
forth
such efforts are conducted exclusively
by current francophone Hispanic bluntest
and sirhan nations or by countries under
French Spanish and so on cultural
political or economic domination
similarly English is massively employed
particularly in higher-level
governmental technological and
educational pursuits by countries and a
former or current anglo-american
domination however English today has
surpassed the Charmed Circle of
anglo-american
Aquino political control and is being
fostered both by its opponents and base
third power
English has become a major medium of
indigenous elites native foreigners of
tourism foreign fariñas of popular media
of technical publications of the
metaphor of mastery of teenage slang and
even of language planning models and
anti models all over the words while the
omnipresence of English also adds to the
opposition to English it obviously fast
as the growth of indigenous non native
varieties finally never before has any
one language being so simultaneously
sought-after
and regulated so that it would grow yet
stay in its place that is be used only
in functions for which it was
authoritative read silence thus if the
continued spread and growth of English
is one aspect of the current
international social linguistics balance
of power another such aspect is the
recurring needs to control regulate or
tame that spreads
we more or less consider that today
whatever the total number non-native
users of English outnumber the native
users the current social English tech
profile of English may be viewed in
terms of three circles more or less
concentric circles the the so called
inner circle as proposed by Castro in
research he dates on this topic refers
to the traditional cultural and
linguistic basis of English it is made
of the u.s.a the UK Canada Australia New
Zealand then we have a outer circle
which is made of Bangladesh Ghana India
Kenya Malaysia Nigeria Pakistan
Philippines Singapore Sri Lanka Tanzania
Zambia
and finally what we call the expanding
circle which contains China Egypt
Indonesia Israel Japan Korea Nepal Saudi
Arabia Taiwan Russia Zimbabwe the
numeral profile is impressive indeed
even if we use a conservative estimates
of the users of English that is
approximately 800 millions about 57% are
non-native users the optimistic figure
of 2 billion users of course increases
the percentage significantly however the
term users is a rather tricky
particularly in the non native context
the vagueness of its use is somewhat
reduced by restricting it to educate its
speakers though by the use of the term 2
we are opening a can of worms the result
of this spread is that formally and
functionally English now has
multicultural identities the term
English does not capture these social
English stick reality I will propose
later in other term which probably does
such former colonies as Bangladesh
Botswana Brunei British colonies Burma
Cameroon British and French Ethiopia
Fiji Gambia Ghana India Israel Kenya
Lesotho Liberia and many others among
the members of the Anglos
english-speaking world today and of
course they contribute to increase this
number what are the faces of spreads of
English today in the contemporary world
now after having studied the situation
and this what I call the three circles I
am studying the phases of spreads the
English language and it's literature
moved toward multiplicity in three broad
sweeps to first Scotland Wales and
Ireland's second North America Australia
New Zealand and South Africa and third
Asia Africa the West Indies the Pacific
and other geographical pockets important
for my present purpose in this wrath of
chronology of some 500 years are the
generalised factors distinguishing each
movement in the first the language
spread by arms politics and culture as
part of an assimilative process through
rearranged field fifth Ohm's
principalities and kingdoms of
anglo-saxon Norman hegemonies over the
cells the Irish for instance have hardly
had difficulty with the English language
only with the English regime and lest we
forget at the setting of the Sun the
greatest English which have been Irish
moreover many of them live today in the
America of their descendants the
difference were part of a symbiotic
relationship arising from a large
measure of shared culture if not of
shared politics in the second movement
language and culture spread as English
speaker spreads major institutions of
identity were transferred at times
replicated and grew strong constants
contact with England's at times
paradoxical maintained bounds that
survived such varied and chronologically
separate happenings as the American War
of Independence
the brewer war in South Africa the
reaction in Australia and New Zealand
when Britain joined the EEC very
recently and South Africa's expulsion
from the Commonwealth also very recently
now if I try to reach a kind of
assessment by comparing the progress of
English with the progress of other
cultures in the past let me mention the
case of Greek and Latin Greek in the
period of Hellenism carried the culture
of intellectualism in science philosophy
on art and became a must for the
educated from Rome to Asia Minor minor
Latin is resuscitated in the Carolingian
period in the ninth ten eighth and ninth
centuries for the necessities of
ecclesiastic and mundane administration
and for seven or eight centuries remains
the vehicle of administration and
African communication in the Western
world the chivalry culture of medieval
aristocracy rising in provence and
france carries these languages often not
clearly separable over the Western world
and beyond from England to the Crusader
States Renaissance Italy brings us into
the modern world with the educated
culture true combines the two traditions
of the humanists and the knight Italian
is part of these equipments and French
again in the 18th and 19th centuries
spreads through the innumerable courts
modeled after Versailles and the
language of the course survives as the
language of international diplomacy
sifting down into the bull Rosie and
remaining a distinctive mark of that
booth was a far beyond Europe in Latin
America the Middle East and Africa ours
is the day as opposed to all that of
American English and you may know that
as early as 780 John Adams made
remarkable statements he proved to be
prophetic when he said English that is
American English
destined to be in the next and
succeeding centuries the next for him
for the 19th and succeeding was a 20th
in our century
so he said English is destined to be in
the next and succeeding centuries more
generally the language of the world then
Latin was in the past of France is in
the present age when he wrote in the end
of the 18th century the reason he said
is obvious because the increasing
population of America and the universal
connection and correspondence with all
nations forced their language into
general use what is remarkable in Adams
statement is his perceptions at such a
pristine stage of the history of the
country indeed in 1780 American English
is still the underdog still a colonial
substandards the colonial regime reaches
its ends but the linguistic class system
is still vigorous a gentleman says for
instance President Witherspoon in 1781
will not imitate the peasants in this
diagnose a diagnosis is not the same as
bilingualism British English is the high
language the prestige language and
American language is the non prestigious
low language royalty the British
tradition means linguistically purism
now British English and American English
really different from each other
the story of spoken American English of
the American colony is indeed one of
linguistic democratization it has been
in existence from before seventy seven
hundred seventeen hundred and it
survives in principle into our days in
the prestige accorded to our relatively
integrated American vernacular I speak
as if I wear myself an American she's
not the case by any means dr. Benjamin
Rush signer of the Declaration of
Independence rejects the British
paradigm she writes the present is the
age of simplicity of writing in America
and no Webster well-known no Webster to
whom language was a national as national
as customs habits and governments since
early in 1789 a divergence of the
language of North America from
future language of England's Webster was
so to speak the discoverer of the
national language of the United States
now tour extents can we say maintain
that British English and American
English a difference linguistically
speaking these two variants of English
British and American far more similar
than they are different ybe British
English and a II American English
each possesses its own range of local
dialectal variants educated usage is by
and large sufficiently similar for easy
intercommunication at the level of
grammar there are remarkably few
differences of consequence though they
are a number of travel differences of
the type in hospital in British English
in the hospital in American English the
book will be published on Friday in
British and it would be published Friday
in American I suppose so at least I
don't know it is easier they collected
usage again American English I already
had my breakfast British English
I've already had all God's my breakfast
which I must confess to me as European
is much more elegance than American
English or do you have your passport
with you yes I do in American English
but English have you got your passport
with you
yes I have and so forth these are minor
differences
I think they cannot lead us to decide
that there is a great difference between
the two norms the British the American
norm as far as phonetic pronunciation is
concerned we have differences I must say
that I as a European a Frenchman having
as you can see a very pure English I did
not understand the Americans at the
beginning first time when I met some
when they pronounced intervocalic T's I
mean T between two vowels because when I
heard the Americans saying a man or a
woman who writes a person who is waiting
for I think I am referring to I heard
Ryder wearing matter exactly as if they
were speaking of a rider waiting and
matter of course the pronunciation is in
fact not AG but what we call in our
phonetic terms a one flap our I mean the
pronunciation I suppose I don't know I
can't imitate it the right way but I
suppose the pronunciation of pretty a
pretty girl is a prairie Prairie with a
prairie
I must confess excuse me for this
aggressiveness that this sounds
extremely vulgar to my ear pretti which
is British is the right pronunciation
course well it's the the British one
well so we cannot say that we have here
two different languages by the maximum
we have two norms although they are they
have they have been many many studies
devoted to studying to work to what
extent English and American are two
different languages there are some
usages which I remind I recall was a
well-known I suppose that according to
studies which have been written on this
subject British English says so long as
you're happy will stay and work an
English as long as you're happy will
stay strange as it may seem in British
English as trained as it may seem in
American shall I take it in but should I
take it in in in American I wish I had
done it in British I wish I would have
done it with probably not quite true or
other try other kinds of vocabulary
particularity I think to cater for is a
British and to cater to is American so
this is an electrical difference lorry
is immediately identified as British as
opposed to truck which is identified as
American nappy & diaper sitting room and
living room dustbin and garbage can
chemist shop and drugstore and so on but
of course all these are no more than
details and cannot I also have blue
movie for pornographic film nudie for
film with much nudity
they cannot suffice to make up the side
that we have to do with two different
languages so leaving the subject of
whether English and American are two
different languages they are just two
norms I will switch to another one which
is more interesting
what are exactly the kind of situations
in which people are when they are
candidates to learning English first we
can have to do with an acquisition or
aspect of the of the problem in
acquisition 'el terms we will speak our
first language second language and
foreign language but we have also
another possibility which is to use a
socio-cultural parameter and in that
respect we will speak of transplanted
and non transplanted speakers of English
we also have a motivational parameter
according to which we can speak of
integrative and instrumental access to
English and finally we have a functional
parameter according to which we have
national language and international
language such are the parameters which I
would propose as useful to decide what
we have to do with now the non native
varieties of English this is what I
would like to treat now I announced that
it is not possible to speak any longer
of English what should we speak off the
terms which has been proposed more and
more by sociolinguists is a
pluralization of the adjective English
they speak of English's and these
English's are the various forms that
English takes according to the country
the non-native varieties of English
because English is refers to these
non-native varieties they furnish
fertile and relatively untapped grounds
for study of the processes of two
linguistic change these varieties have
grown up in recent times as second
languages in multilingual former
colonies of Great Britain hence the
alternative terms new English's third
world Englishes and also an nve the
famous and envied which means non native
varieties of English these and nve it
refers to the English is used in many
former colonies of Britain or the United
States in which English is not a native
language but in acquired a second
language the last area to come under
colonization whether as British colonies
or as protectorates of Australia our New
Zealand's with South Pacific Islands
Tonga Samoa Nauru Fiji Papua New Guinea
to value Ellis Islands the drill bores
and the Solomon Islands which were
colonized in the late 19th and early
20th centuries all are independent now
while the Cook Islands American Samoa
new way and the Turk allows are not yet
free they allergists say without
polymerizing
territories under American influence all
these territories have English as a
second language now we can also speak of
IV es 2 which indigenized varieties of
English and these indigenous rise of
English are more or less the same as the
NVE and they have been neglected very
long and only recently have the linguist
and sociolinguists become aware of the
importance of studying these varieties
so what I would like to do now is to
propose a study of some of these
variants let me first of all mention the
engine variants which are among the most
important number
a wide range of styles can be found in a
small book
bah-ha the 18 year old illiterate
sweeper who is the title character often
seems quite right like in thought as
well as in speech but he represents what
kind of few such many engines less
educated engines have of English
occasionally the reader encounters
dialogues such as this my father is ill
replied Becca so I'm going to sweep the
roads in town and the temple courtyard
in his stead
so he uses ill which seems probably a
bit odd to a native speakers ear and he
says also in his stead instead of
instead he also used Indian words such
as assad's which means honour banya
which means merchant caste gulab margin
which is Indian sweets varieties which
means England abroad abroad in fact
villi cat is an Arabic word which has
been burrowed through Islamization by
the engines and which refers to a
country in this particular case it
refers to England's and also Swadeshi
which is an Indian word meaning native
or indigenous this is a sample of Indian
English but of course I might mention
many other ones another one I take from
simply the titles of newspapers in which
almost 3/4 of the title are made of
Indian words which are not
understandable to native English speaker
of United Kingdom or United States for
example in the rising in Nepal in
Kathmandu 1978 panchayat system upholds
ideals of human rights in the Hindustan
Times more subsidy for goober gas plants
in the Bangladesh observer Krissy Bank
branch needs in dawn a journal from
Lahore December 1979 Shariat calls for
attack in the Sunday Times of Singapore
Indian Muslims are bumiputra in the
Statesmen of New Delhi GNU
Joe halal National University Karim
Shari begin Dartmouth and so on of
course this is understandable only in an
Indian context a much more extreme case
is when syntax itself is Indian
while the vocabulary is English for
example in an example I have here a
linguist overheard a young female Fiji
Indian sales clerk
she said Sheila account book use Kara I
think account book use is the reverse
order as opposed to that of English and
her eyes about to make so it means in
fact in translation
Sheila used the account book I think and
in order to translate used she uses the
Kara to make and she put the object
compliment before instead of after as is
the usage in English this is typical of
a new syntax in you word order which of
course is totally understandable in
English of native speakers now let me
give you some other examples but before
I switch to the examples I like to well
another one is the example of Malaysian
English in which we find such usages as
the one as this one in a article in a
newspaper equally certainly 25 authors
and two editors do not know enough to
write this book and by virtue of
knowledge ease and viewpoints they may
not provide as cohesive a book as a
single author in other examples parents
eagerness to teach their six-month-old
children the pre-linguistic routine
bye-bye is one evidence of their desire
to show that the baby is on its way to
being a socialized person I think
knowledge is in the parole is an
American and I think one evidence with
one before the mass abstract noun
evidence is also an American to some
extent this usage was in Malaysia I mean
part of the world in which British
English was more influential
American English might be borrowed from
British usage in which it is possible to
privilege abstract or mass nouns since
for example in British eternals we find
things which would probably be a frown
upon in American English such as
intimidations in the plural or other as
tract word nouns use used in the proven
- these examples are mentioned he in
order to show what kind of Asian ization
of English takes place in Malaysia now
let me mention examples of African
ization of English this is taken from a
letter a personal letter to which I had
accessed some years ago a inhabitant of
Nigeria writes to his relatives with
much pleasure and respect I inscribe you
these few lines this few lines and with
the hope that it will meet you in good
condition of health this seems to be
literally translated from house' the
language of this nigerian childs other
examples taken from people living in
Kenya and Tanzania
let's trunk football team be organized
she won by overwhelming majority without
the article she gave me tough time I'm
going to cinema I'm going to post office
of course these speakers they have as a
native tongue a language doesn't have
any article in this context so they
simply transfer their habits into their
English I may continue with the
interview or examine few more
applications or many other now in other
which is taken from the South East of
Nigeria where EBU a well-known African
languages speak spoken in which I
overheard this you'll see Reds said the
angry carpenter to the frightened boy
another example to my surprise I found
him the driver resting under steer and
fall asleep as a result she lost control
of the city
in other sentence I asked her to dance
but she cut me another example they must
pay the town council so these usages are
taken from African languages from Igbo
in this particular case to see red means
it's a threat to harm or punish a person
the steer here means a steering wheel
and the verb to cut in the sentence on I
asked her to dance but she cut me means
she refused to dance with me so this is
another examples of the way English is
Africanized in this context
other examples are still you have to be
careful with these being two boys or
there's been two men bintu is a special
African expression which is taken from
she has been to Britain and it refers to
anyone who has traveled overseas
particularly to Britain another example
we stopped at our - to buy some Bush
Bush meats which means game in fact in
native English and I saw you I show
you're my dear I saw you're my dear at
the church you're my Germans means your
girlfriends or your boyfriend's my dear
we being put together in order to
constitute an expression which
corresponds to girl or boyfriend in
English I have been going to the small
room a lot sir means to the toilets and
I was a tight friend of your sister
tight friend of course does not
correspond to anything clear for a
native speaker of English and it means a
close or intimates friends it's almost
literally translated from African
languages I could multiply the languages
but I will limit myself to some more
only house are Lingala Swahili in
Republic of Congo also have many uses
which do not correspond to the English
American norm for example don't drag
your feet son walk quick quick the read
application of quick means very quickly
life is a big challenge you
to take its small small or you are
eating too fast Li take your time and
each slow slow these way of replicating
adverbs is simply the formation in many
African languages of the superlative and
or or in an intensive which is a
grammatical process of course unknown in
English although it's not quite unknown
in spoken English but it is not
correspond to the written norm of
English other examples
he is my bench man meaning he's my crony
or intimate friend he Bluffs too much
love meaning here being arrogance or
trying to be guy people or the fellow is
too boisterous too much the storekeeper
sets here virtuous mean bad tempered or
quarrelsome other examples
I was coupled at the dance it means I
found a dancing partner or are you
nauseating for Nigeria yet are you
homesick it means or I opened the door
and visualized a very familiar face it
means I saw if to visualize a familiar
face sorry not to have been chance to
write before this is also in Africanism
and many other the same type voice out
for voice discuss about for discuss
congratulate for for congratulate on and
many others an allograft which I myself
which I was myself an actor or a
testimony is one when one important
personality in Nigeria while visiting a
partner linguistics was told that this
department was interested in research or
Nigerian English he immediately
commented that that was a waste of time
as there was no such thing as Nigerian
English he said but a few minutes later
he said on being interrupted let me land
and tooand is the Nigerian equivalent of
let me finish so he himself of course
spoke a variant of Nigerian English now
we also have Chinese English and it it
began as a pigeon in Chinese soon as the
beginning of the 19th century and this
Chinese English was very different from
standard English for example consider
the following sentence which I will try
to translate tailor my have got one
piece plenty handsome silk my want you
make one nice evening dress here the
might is used for me and this kind of
creolization
in which the possessive is the same
other personal pronoun is typical of
many Creoles although not universally
Creole it means I mean it corresponds to
a regularization of the morphology and
it makes it much more clear than it is
in languages such as English in which we
differentiate between word classes which
are not really necessary in terms of
economy another example taken from China
from Chinese in China's we have examples
like this one do some people understand
Chinese well may I mention in Chinese
nasi bar once washing away any weight
Ranjan it songs hai ye bow in Sweden
wait Rhonda Neutron champagne diamond
young this is a structure which is
directly inspired by English it puts the
object compliment in the wrong place and
it makes an inversion which is not
Chinese but all the words are literally
Chinese so word order can be transformed
by the model of Chinese even when their
worlds themselves the lexicon remain
there's something quite Chinese this is
another example of the way languages are
recognized Japanese is also an
interesting example Marie are Inori who
was first the first Minister of
Education of the new modern Japan claim
that I'm I cite our meager language
which can never be of any use outside of
our islands is doomed to yield to the
domination of the English Tong
especially when the power of steam and
electricity will have pervaded the lands
she proposed to replace Japanese bluntly
by English but the Japanese did not do
that what did they do they are probably
the one among the country in the world
in which the borrowed word from English
are the most numerous it is
extraordinary how many borough term of
course Japan eyes with the Japanese
phonetic exist in nowadays Japanese they
are English but not identifiable not
recognizable to someone who does not
know their origin for example we have
blue boy put abolish his playboy
pronouncing the Japanese way and as you
know one of the same consonant in
Japanese so and also the Japanese is a
consonant vowel consonant vowel concern
of our language so it cannot say playboy
is person transformed it into pure boy
and also magical power magical power for
magic power or also duchy waifu for
darts wife - wife is an inflatable bed
partner
other examples of Japanese English are
Hulu pseudo easy to make as you know in
Japanese studio what she was she master
cheetah a well-known Japanese verb and
they they take an English word which is
in this case the the a preposition up
and they push through after and push
through which means to make up means in
fact to improve or go up and we have
many other such uses in Japanese today
we also have Chris Christmas Christmas
which is Christ mass we have macaroon or
ado macaroon radishes McDonald's
restaurant which is restaurant and
even a guru nonsense good innocence
erotic grotesque nonsense or do misoo
which is old miss to refer to a spinster
Masuka me mass communication one-piece
suit for one-piece dress tableau speech
for table speech after dinner speech
after whom for at home and even iew for
i love you
these are some ways of japanese
transformation of english or japanese
ation of english now this is all the
more astonishing as Japan was never a
British or American territory Japan was
never colonized by the British who as
well left a linguistic legacy in the
form of civil service requirements
government legislation or a prestige
language such factors must have
encouraged people to become fluent in
spoken and written English English was
never the length of the Japanese public
school system though there were
intellectual incentives to incur at
least a reading knowledge most important
japan has never had the cultural and
linguistic pluralism which made English
convenient as a lingua franca at least
or a national language at most in short
English in Japan was never or never
became institutionalized
however they developed a kind of
Japanese English which I gave you some
samples this also reaches European
languages and since the matter is
enormous
I will contain myself with mentioning
German borrowing such as English words
which are directly introduced in the
context of a nautical written in German
we have for example
HiFi aftershave lotion we have
brainwashing for game fish
spearhead force PDFs Pizza climber for
clitoral involved for bikal and other
such examples let us see if you don't
mind speech now switch now to French
French has twice been a world language
itself in the twelfth century as you may
know and again from the 17th to the 19th
century but twice it has also been on
the passive end on the process in the
sixteenth century when the giant of the
Renaissance Italy covered the West with
Italian isms and now in the 20th century
when we have the impact of Americanisms
the Italian episode are the difference
in certain ways from the American is of
considerable interest to us since it has
concluded it allows us to evaluate from
a historical perspective those facets
which in the present-day case of
American English are still in the midst
of evolution the impact of the Italian
Renaissance heard the French prides it
hurt what humanistic tradition labeled
the fql Goolwa the Gallic Hercules in
states where citizens feel a political
cultural integrity language turns into
their foremost symbol of national
defense defense phrasing thank you
linguistic Patriots consider borrowing
anti-patriotic Jubilee the greatest
showing list of the times wrote in 1549
the same natural law which requires
everyone to define his birthplace
likewise obliges us to watch over the
dignity of our language similarly the
foreign language turns into a symbol of
the foreigner himself since he is
disliked his language will be disliked
now the Battle of a French
intelligentsia against Americanisms
is not devolved from a certain
conservative political and cultural
attitude the anti art issue symbolizes
the belief in tradition and norm in
elitism in the electro skepticism toward
technology this is the opinion of many
English
speaking linguists but so far I agree
but one of them adds conservatism in
France linguist conservatism symbolizes
an anti-democratic reaction against the
women the young and mass culture
it symbolizes anti-americanism and a
rejection of multilingualism and
multiculturalism the attitude against
American isms in short reflects the
struggle against the cultural and social
revolution which marks the decline of
the traditional French civilization this
is what Rene kahan and American
sociolinguists arise I must say I don't
agree why because in fact the way many
linguists and many intellectual writers
and so on in France react against what
they feel as an invasion of American
words or as a current simple
substitution of English to French in
many context is not a reaction which is
limited to rights millou's leftists also
are also concerned that this attitude in
general what we what we aim at when
defining French and when trying not only
in a defensive valued but so in an
offensive want to promote it is to
propose other models because we feel
that in many cases the domination of the
world by one at the same language is not
something to be recommended because it
results in in a in a world in which we
have nothing to be a narrative about
just one language one culture of course
this is just a an idealized possible
future which will not I think take place
but it is the thing against which the
people who want to preserve
multiculturalism multilingualism fights
and I think that to that extent they are
not wrong so I will come back to this
later
it was just a reflection on the way
a part of the transcultural would reacts
to the pressure of English throughout
the non-english mother-tongue world
English is recurrently associated with
practical and powerful pursuits this
becomes evident with the image of French
and on the other hand with that of local
Integrative languages with that have
been fairly recently standardized
relative to the latter
English is viewed as less suitable for
military operations local soldiers do
not know that much English yet for lying
joking cursing or beginning the
beginning English is not adapted at all
and for under mediated prayer on the
other hand English is recurrently viewed
as more suitable than local Integrative
languages for science international
diplomacy industry commerce high rattori
and pop songs of course now the image of
English with a V French is even more
revealing in that the former has risen
and the letter has begun to fall in the
international balance of power in the
third world excluding former Anglophone
and francophone colonies French is
considered more suitable than English
for only one function this is what years
were fishman a well-known social are
socialists of yesterday University
writes I don't agree but I mentioned
what he says it is considered French is
considered more suitable than English
for only one function which is opera it
has considered the equal of English for
reading good novels or poetry and for
personal prayer the local integrity of
language being widely viewed as superior
to both English and French in this
connection which is obvious but outside
the reading of aesthetics the ugly
duckling
Joshua Fishman writes reigns supreme
French is widely viewed as more
beautiful more musical pleasant rhythmic
refined intimate pure soothing graceful
tender and lovely but English is viewed
as richer more precise more logical more
sophisticated and more competence
related I must say
this is a widespread prejudice which to
me is on the brink of requite ridiculous
this is a even under the pan of just a
freshman with who is a a well-known a
prestigious linguist I think this should
not be written let me just tackle one
aspect of this subject which is twisted
precision you may know that professional
linguist like me generally do not commit
themselves to in debate such as to what
extent is one language more Prasad than
the other one because the notion of
precision is a relative notion and for
me for any I suppose for any
professional language the most precise
language is the one which is native to
you to each of you of course there is no
precision in itself as an abstract
concept however I would like to adduce
an example which I have recently
discovered which might be interesting if
I propose it to you right to your
thinking and in that case it seems that
in a very politicized context French is
reacted to as much more precise than
English this refers to resolution 242 of
the new United Nations you may know that
the mmm are bein countries have chosen
the French version of the treaties and
Israel has chosen the British the
English version why the British the
English version says we recommend
probably they said we order withdrawal
immediate it was in 1968 after the
famous war six days war we recommend
withdrawal of Israeli Armed Forces from
occupied territories this is the English
version in English when you have a
plural term like territories you may not
use the article so from occupied
territories is a normal English way of
seeing
and from the occupied territories could
be said but in this particular case I'm
not in if speak of English I don't know
but it seems to me that this lack of
article is the more natural way of
speaking so withdrawal of acute of
Israeli Armed Forces from occupied
territories in French as opposed to that
we cannot avoid using the article we
must choose either the article or no
article so this yields wrote a wrote a
withdrawal to retract the troop Israel
yen of Israeli armed troops date little
aa QP D means from the or the teleplay
occupation if I say they tell to occupy
which is a choice
it means of all the travel toys which
have been occupied by the Israelis if I
say do teleplay occupy it means of some
of these territories and in French we
have to choose so the French version
which is the one recommended by the
Arabs says has chosen Dietrich occupy
which means that Israel Israel has to
withdraw his troops from all occupied
territories
whereas English allows one to interpret
in ambiguous terms either as from some
of these territories or from all of them
this is an example we might mention many
other ones we might also because of
course this is very active matter
mention examples in which it is English
which is more precise it depends on the
kind of circumstance a French was used
to be in the past is no more now the
language of diplomacy I do not as a
professional linguist make part of those
who purport that French is a clear
precise language as I said to each of us
the most the clearest the one we master
most but what I can call your attention
to is that in certain contexts like this
one which is a very politicized with
political context the French version can
turn out to be the more precise one and
so what fishman writes here needs to
some extent wrong
he adds English is less loved but more
used French is more loved but less used
nature grows a vacuum which is a
medieval expression you know a well
known as the functional load of a
formerly prestigious variety declines
effect rushes in to take up the slack
the non francophone world has nothing
but love for French he says and in the
cruel wheel word that is signed that is
a sign of a weakness the displacement of
Irish is suffused with love the
replacement of a dish which is a
well-known matter for Joshua Fishman is
accompanied by panegyrics as to its
intimacy and authenticity English gets
along without love without size without
tears and almost without effect of
enecon this is not true there is an
effective access to English for many
speakers of it which are speakers not
native speakers of English but we have
cried it's so I don't agree that English
is something just as unmarked as Fishman
writes English gets along without love
without side thou tears and almost
without effect of any kind in a world
where echo no technical superiority is
what really counts the heightened
aesthetic affective image of French
smacks of witness innocence and
triviality this is the opinion washed by
a well-known social linguist I am not
sure that many linguists have seen
myself will agree with it now this
situation which I have tried to describe
according to which English is under the
form of native English in one case a
minority of course and in another case
in the form of non native varieties or
indigenous varieties of English or of
English is in the plural
this general situation is viewed or
reacted to by a great part of
intellectuals Oliver
the world something not completely
acceptable why because they they sense
they feel that having a language which
serves the role of being the second
language for people whose language is
not known to each other when they are
dialoguing it's not necessarily
something good when it turns out that
this language belongs to countries
Canada United States Australia New
Zealand South Africa which turned out to
be a more the most powerful in the world
this makes English much less acceptable
then if it were not the case that it
belongs to these countries this of
course is do large extent a political
matter and as a result people
necessarily accept such a situation and
I would like to mention a text which was
submitted to me recently by an American
University professor he is American the
text which sounds very strange coming
from an American but what he says might
be interesting to mention and I received
this one on internet one months ago he
says according to the latest video
supplied by global reach English content
of our internet messages worldwide
dropped below 50% it is clear that as
the net gas global it also does
multilingual the internet was born in
English but it has become quite obvious
that those who attempted to promote it
through the use of English only slowed
down its development rather rather than
accelerating it once again we are
discovering that localization is the key
for the international dissemination of
any tool and more especially when that
tool is designed to facilitate
communication it is well known that
anyone who is serious about pursuing
commercial endeavors has to use his
customers language this policy which is
by the way I add myself that of Germany
to a lesser extent much lesser extent
that of French was especially pushed by
firms that sort expansion through the
development of international markets in
the
old days the success of firms such as
IBM as far as the Americans are
concerned residue on this approach IBM
intelligently translated all technical
manuals offered seminars and training in
over 20 languages
IBM went as far as translating
push-button levels on its hardware and
even coining new fine words that was the
case for instance with ordinator which
is now the French word for computer I
must here intervene this is quite wrong
od network was not invented by IBM it
was invented by a French Latinist
Latin professor in the Sorbonne
jean-pierre a who proposed it to the
earth nor Academie Francaise as the
terminology and who said instead of
computer which was beginning then to
introduce itself in French we should use
a word which shows that the machine in
question is able to ordinate in the
meaning of organize together many data
many elements of information and the
best word for that is alternator which
he was a Catholic and of course he
thought of organization during the
consecration were priests but he took it
from the ecclesiastical vocabulary but
there was a success and we know because
this has a date and there are documents
that auditor was proposed by this French
professor of Latin and not by IBM but
this does not stop me from recognizing
that iBM has proposed many felicitous in
neologisms
the success of Microsoft this professor
adds mostly relied on the same approach
as far back as 90 1995 Microsoft had
already 60% of its market outside
english-speaking countries again few
people and analysts note that this
tremendous success rested less on the
quality of Microsoft products than the
capability of the company to sell in its
customer songs the Internet is supposed
to facilitate international
communication not to preclude it yet it
is surprising to find out
that many Internet users believe that
restricting expression to English only
on the net is necessary to bridge our
differences and make it possible for us
to fully understand one another is
English really adequate in this context
English is the native tongue to a bear
six percent of the world population and
even though it is widely studied over
seventy percent of the world population
has no knowledge of it if twenty percent
or so of the world population has some
knowledge of English as a second
language those of us who travel a lot
can testify that fluency in English in
non-english speaking countries is just
wishful thinking it applies to me as you
can see if English may be understood
well enough to us for us to check into a
hotel to check in check into a hotel
order a meal or tell a cabbie where to
take us it does not often allow us to go
much beyond addressing our most
immediate needs true English has been
widely adopted as the international
language for science but can those of us
who attend international conferences
honestly tell us that foreigners can
make themself understood in English as
well as we can
haven't we noticed that apart from a few
exceptions even highly educated
professionals whose mother tongue is not
English have a much harder time to
address our questions and more
especially when their work is being
questioned and criticized are we blind
to the post-conference syndrome that
affects most of the participants who
speak English as a second language when
they congregate and regroup as soon as
the plenary session is over
to communicate freely in their own
native tongues in the hard sciences and
in technology when PowerPoint slides are
transparent and transparencies can't
compensate for the lack of fluency to
present an experimental setup a pilot
plant or a bunch of equations to model
physical phenomena English does not seem
to be much of an impediment but can we
really expect a top-level scholar in
psychology in social science in history
or in literature be able to present his
research in a fully effective way and in
a manner as convincing and persuasive
as if he was conducting I would have
written as if he where as if he were but
the American writers if he was as if he
was conducing his talk in his own native
tongue of course not
the widely known is a key leader used to
give his talks in English when he
traveled to the US until his American
agencies told him to switch back to
French why even though they did not
fully master the French language
Dalida was far more understandable to
them in his own native talk and even
more so are they were already familiar
with his work language is not neutral
and translation implies switching over
to a different system of coordinates by
adapting English as a means for real
international communication I will
necessarily have to adapt to the English
speaking psyche and use references that
are coming to english-speaking countries
and anglo-american culture thereby
losing in the process the best of my
message as a minority what right do
native English speakers have to foist
English upon a word majority can we ever
expect non English speakers to master
English as well as those who have it as
the native tongue
most of the time a basic night of German
French and English was sufficient in the
olden days
today the free flow of scientific and
technical information is then then in
the 19th century the free flow of
scientific and technical information
went unhampered by multilingualism on
the contrary it seems to have boosted
creativity scientific creativity feeds
on language and language structures that
the linguist Benjamin Lee Whorf has
clearly shown scientists who gives up
his own native tongue to conduct his
work can never reach full potential and
often he will be limited to technical
contributions only even though he is
able to do much more the tremendous
variety of languages appears less
awesome when we delineate language
families inside which the acquisition of
novel another idiom can be made
relatively effortless a hundred years
ago in Europe serious students studied
two or three foreign languages not to
become fluent and interpreters but
because they were mess no because they
were mesmerized by any superior
civilization but to be able to
understand their neighbors and mostly
those who made significant contribution
to their professional fields so he
concluded by saying international forums
and discussion groups should welcome
contributions in all languages if their
participants were really seeking the
best and most interesting contributions
instead the internet shows today
incredible mediocrity while the average
citizen thinks the internet brings him
the world the serious intellectual has
returned to his book lecture halls
conferences and had too had discussions
and roundtable I don't say that I agree
fully with this and round tables that
gather will thought challenging
professionals and researchers if people
want the best from the internet they
have to invite back the bests by first
realizing that original thoughts
automatically entailed the use of
original modes of expression this is the
opinion forged by someone an American
professor who
is aware or conscious of the dangers of
this uniformization by English
what would I myself propose as a
conclusion in in all that I think
English is in fact not so much a threat
as it is often said to be why first
because although much more English
speakers than the one the ones to which
it is native exist all over the world it
is native to a small minority of the
world's second because it gives rise to
new forms of languages new English's
which might by progressive
transformations yield new languages
between which there would not be any
communication this is the story of latin
yielding propagates is spanish romanian
french and italian so called neo latin
aromas languages and this is the fate
the word faith is not the felicity
because it is not something that it is
just the the normal result of evolution
and this kind of transformation of
languages which come from a is the same
trunk the same original source is
something which happens a has always
happened in the world in space and in
time so it will it has begun to happen
to english as it does happen to french
also in former french colonial
territories in which there are some from
the french to which I refer just today
in in a class or one of you which are
getting more and more different from
French such as the spoken in France so
this second reason not to be anxious
about the future is for me an important
one a third one is that English is a
round upon by those who fend for
diversity which means that many people
not only in the so-called edits but also
in the average public react to the
danger of uniformization which is
the result of a very dangerous pretext
often provided by people who argue in
favor of English saying that when we
have just one language this allows us to
communicate this avoids awards it avoid
misunderstanding and so on this is not
true at all we have the example to cite
every recent one of former Yugoslavia in
which the Croats and the Serbs have
thought violently against it on another
each other although they speak more or
less the same language today I receive
many letters threatening letters from
Zagreb the capital of crash' saying
please professor Rajesh please all of
you
western linguist stops speaking of
serbo-croatian we do because
serbo-croatian although for reasons of
nationalism acceptable nationalism the
class want to individuals themselves and
to be considered a speaker of another
language it is true that
serbo-croatian is a language a unified
one if we accept if we use a criterion
faced communication Serbs can
communicate in Serb with crowds
communicating so in short it is of
course one of the same language which
has regional variants like any other
human language so they speak the same
religion however this is not this is not
stop them from fighting and from
[Music]
separating from each other in the
beginning of the 90s and this was a very
fierce war of which you are aware all of
you so this is just one example which
for lack of time I give in order to
demonstrate that it is not true that one
and the same language is a promise of
peace or this is an illusion and a
prejudice against which I must react so
in what case could English become a real
danger for languages just in one case if
English not content with being what it
is now in many countries in the world
with what I said at the beginning of
this talk I mean a second language in
indigenized variety which exists which
coexist side by side with the
vernacular languages of the people if
English not content with being this was
stuff substituted substituted for the
other ones in private life in the homes
of of every family
if English became from the present state
of a second language in many countries
English as I said which much more
English speakers than there once to
which to whom it is native if it became
the first language of all these
countries in other words if English knew
the same future as Latin days when it
was substituted when languages of
conquered Western Europe where
substituted for by Latin garish garnish
disappeared that way
Etruscan also dashing in present-day
Romania which was then Dacia they
disappeared in that way we do not know
any word of these languages because
Latin replaced them and Latin was
introduced not only in public life not
in the streets but also in private life
so the problem this will be my latest
conclusion is to what extent can English
be an example of the same process I mean
is English in the present situation of
the world a language which can replace
by suppression by being substituted for
all these languages all the language
which are native to the people of most
countries I must say in this case only
would I accept to say that English is a
threat to the languages in question I
think this is not the case and I'm not
sure it will ever be the case thank you
very much
[Applause]
I'm sorry for taking too long yes the
observation relates to your discussion
of Fishman and his this adjectives to
describe French verses it occurs to be
as I was listening to that list that it
corresponds very closely to stereotypic
notions of masculinity versus feminine
in listening to that I thinking that it
reminded me of the degree to which
Germany during the political imaginary
of France as a female that's other
defect or series and that's and and I
find it somewhat ironic that Fishman is
a Jew and that he's applying these
perhaps or it seems with no
self-consciousness which this makes my
question which is totally naive in your
discipline and also need six proper yes
yes discipline linguistic is there a
German branch of the 20th century of
scholarship does some of it date from
and to what extent a linguist embrace or
have you well I'll take good question
you said that the adjectives which
qualify French and English in the text I
mentioned from your Joshua Fishman
represent a stereotype a civilized
thinking which of course is my opinion
too I must say that if I were a woman
myself is not the case as you see I
would I would think that this is it
unacceptable anti-feminist and matched
view because it is quite ridiculous to
associate certain things with women and
other ones with men women are not
necessarily more tender or more and so
on more feminine in the masculine scent
of the world and men are not the
contrary this is quite a inspiration
which is quite anti-feminist which I
can't accept now what is behind this
kind of
inspiration you ask whether I know of
German researchers scholars as soon as
soon as the end of the 18th century and
beginning of their women Romantic period
now such as Hatter the Grimm of the
Grimm brothers the Schlegel's and many
of the well-known German scholars who by
the way we're the founders of
linguistics and the ones who used the
word for the first time in history had a
certain tendency that's true to
associate language with certain
psychological cultural settings and this
is a thinking which of course today
appraised as completely obsolete and
reactionary but it dominated German
thinking during a long time this is true
its formations what to is it's I study
metaphoric in another context that's
right that's right
yes fully acknowledging that it didn't
fit I'm wondering if your sub-discipline
inevitably it has to be drawn
which are ideologically rated I can
mention a fact which probably you know
as a testimony of the importance of the
way a political power views language I
have documents which I found some years
ago on Hitler's attitudes to German he
was as you know Austrian and he had a
very strong Austrian accent he has a
very accurate voice I have heard his
voice and records and he's Austrian
accent was jeered at at the beginning
jeered at mocked laughed at and
ridiculed at the beginning when he's at
not yet when he did not did not yet have
power I said quite later and as soon as
he became more and more powerful all the
Germans who did not pronounce Dominus he
did imitate his pronunciation and in
articles I have we see that not only in
phonetics but also in morphology and in
the lexicon many words which are which
were Hitler would wear white pride in
German resuming the hoenn is a period so
this I just mentioned this fact I know
to what extent it it responds to your
query but I just mean by that that it is
quite possible to politicize a form in
norm of a language through a certain
regime and to associate a certain
conception of the language to a certain
regime which this is which it is little
known but assessed and it existed this
is which took place what what took place
in the during the Second World War
to what extent does that correspond to
you
yes words that you use your self I
recognize one of them maybe someone else
someone at Benson's did you write the
translation that you were reading anyway
one word is passing relates to
that is when you use the word passive
which is really a sexualized metaphor to
refer to the condition of a language
getting a lot of words from another life
today usually when they would pass
through my cell for example that's not a
metaphor that normally is used to
describe that post 1066 period English I
think many more words from French to
English where you quite subjective know
the reason very simple not far to seek a
learning is from British both professors
so their way they pronounced it was the
one I tried to imitate and when I went
for the first time in America I was
startled by the way Americans pronounce
English because it was not mine
and so my reaction verga for which I
apologize of course it is an aggression
and I don't known to be aggressive
because the way I reacted to this kind
and something that is a problem no
van-gogh is a way is a word I am quite
ready to recognize it is a word which is
completely subjective as you use it as I
said to refer to a part of my biography
in which I discovered the way Americans
pronounce English which was not the one
that when I have been taught but well
it's the most widespread today but I I
grew up in another kind of Englishman
although although as you may as may
observe many of my own way of
pronouncing a more or less inspired by
the American Way of pronouncing well the
world Verger is not a good word and I I
do not I do not use it as a as a
scientific quote is quite subjective one
as far as passive is concerns I will
probably more reluctance more loath to
reject it for every simple reason is
just a matter of terminology if by
passively mean a language which accepts
or receives a great a huge amount of
borrowed words then the word is not
marked more than just referring to that
and we have many languages which in this
respect passive and if you want to avoid
the implications of the word passive we
will just say opens to borrowing words
and which is the case of many languages
other ones as you know Icelandic for
example Fijian by the way both of them
are language of islanders they are not
passive in this respect because they do
not borrow and they are also watched by
purists who want to tap the original
fund in order for them to find
neologisms they do not want to borrow so
there is there is a choice there are two
attitudes in neurology either we borrow
great masses of words to translate new
notions which correspond to the modern
technical world or we exclusively resort
to words from the original fans in the
case of Icelandic old Norrish which is
the origin of all centenarian languages
for as the case of Arabic it is the same
thing and I somewhere somewhere
sometimes cite Israeli Hebrew and Arabic
in this respect are very characteristic
when
it came to a designating atomic bomb the
the Arab young scholars who were asked
by the government's to look for a word
because the Quran does not speak of
atomic bomb they took it does someone
speak Arabic here they took a route from
the Quran they took Daraa which means a
parcel because the Prophet says land of
the RAM in the height field yonder
yugi-boy alaikum and and learnt the kun
kathleen in this context here the
Prophet said you will not bring any
puzzle any parcel of good to the
paradise if you don't follow my my
religion and the word parcel which is a
Quranic world in the to that extent very
prestigious was chosen by the the
elements colors to express atomic of
course it was not a good word because
atomic is a Greek word which means which
cannot be cut more ah is privative and
Tom is a Thomas the Greek cuisine means
a thing which you cannot cut further it
is the the last result of a cutting
operation but the Arabians thought that
they had to instead of borrowing the
world a bomb atomic bomb to take a word
from the Quran because it is respectable
was the the Israelis adopted with just
the kind of phonetic transformation
bomba a Tomica without any further ado
this means that there is a kind of
political attitude behind the choice of
knowledge isms either we are passive in
the sense which I promised myself to use
and means open to borrowing without much
hesitation not reluctant or we consider
that neurology is to a large extent a
political activity and there is a
national or nationalist implication
behind and this is what many languages
in the modern would give us examples of
I would say
to question his threat
the United States where so many Native
American languages are disappearing the
way to Ken Hale there was a linguist
here spent his life trying to rescue
many of these languages I did not refer
to that because was the sake of my talk
of just today I was I devoted it excuse
me to the subject we are treating so I
spoke about American Indian language is
disappearing English but they're not
really
this is English words being adapted to
the Japanese system and thoroughly
adapted to it to such an extent that
many Japanese don't even know that these
terms
tomatoes yeah the question to me is the
Japanese are not particularly concerned
about this there's not much opposition
to this there was in the 1930s in the
military regime where they did make this
effort to create scientific
technological terms from old Chinese
roots but unlike the French the Japanese
are not concerned I know they are not
concerned about this in Lux
of what we think of as English words
it's true it's true I wonder you have a
comment the other question is that you
change our syntax in Chinese which is
quite interesting because
it complicates the political question
Chinese in general does not try to sound
out English words they look for Chinese
roots Britain terms and yes some of
Chinese syntax and word order is now
being affected by English influences
this is a subtler difference I haven't
seen Chinese objective examples of this
yes
to begin with the end and concerning the
Chinese Chinese syntax you u.s. I not
just yourself how do you know that who
meaning and is not normally used in
traditional Chinese every time we
conjunct things and is not as often used
as the end and the a of English and
French and now we have texts which are
full of who who wears the hood of
genuine Chinese is a preposition meaning
with and hurt her young can't hi young
correct high fat high it home agreeing
with him and this her which is Chinese
heels today a conjunction of
coordination which did exist in fact in
Chinese but and a much lesser extent and
which is pervading invading the Chinese
same tax and morphology this is an
example among many other ones another
one is that in you you note in you which
are the determined determiner in the non
group actually water water true Rossi a
true or what would who the the book I
read the book I wrote in Chinese when we
have between the subject the war no
subject which is not not it is often
left away and they do a very long
stretch of words the Chinese avoid
having this day and they prepare commute
and choose another structure but Chinese
which is cut on English has very very
long relative prepositions with do which
are not Chinese and I have many examples
of that and I was referring to that
exactly now as far as the first part of
the question is concerned you are quite
right and I will accept that I
exaggerated to some extent and should
not speak so much of Americanized
Japanese Japanese as of a very large
amount of borrowings I would say I'm not
a specialty I speak Japanese fluently
but I what I see when I when I when I
give talks in Japanese in Japan when I'm
invited when I speak with the people
later what I see is that I would
strongly tend to think that there is a
continually in Japanese history just the
same way as in the 6th century this
country of samurais which was illiterate
adopted Chinese characters just in the
same way as it adopted an enormous
amount of Chinese by syllable by
syllable which it pronounced the
Japanese way which we which were what we
call sino-japanese in the same way
recently it has adapted in a great great
many English Brotherhood words which
lead me to think which is it is
hypothesis which has a cultural or socio
cultural and philosophical implication
I'm not a philosopher and don't want to
indulge in facilities or things which
could be contradicted but it pleased me
to think that as opposed to French as
you said yourself and you say
unlike French in which language is a
very politicized and very nationalistic
the thing of which French have a very
high conscience and which has always
been associated with power under the
monarchy just the same as another
Republic on the contrary contrary to
that in Japan it seems to me that
language is not a political matter in
France it is a very strongly political
matter and the reaction of many French
intellectuals against Americanization is
directly drawn from this psychology
which in the kind of Japan is almost
none existence is what I would propose
I'm going to ask make an observation a
question from a different perspective
which is I think
which is who were talking about
differences in in English largely in
terms of different countries I what of
real space really no Geographic space
you mentioned a little of the Internet
I think it's by no coincidence that the
world wide web was invented by an
Englishman working in a Franco from the
city for an international physics and
that one of the ways that English really
is becoming is within science and
technology and in certain fields such as
physics biology computer science the
discourse is really modeling and I was
just wondering what your take on and
there's good reasons for that in the
sense that it has to be one
because there's a premium placed on
precision I had a question do you are
you able to appreciate the quality and
the correctness of their English these
scholars who are not if his speakers and
do you not think that as the text i read
strongly suggests there is an unequal
situation because many of these
non-native speakers are mainly true in
scientific congress a resort to it
cannot express their thought as fully as
they would if they used the native
tongues I'm not sure
[Music]
what gives you what gives you a good
argument which of course I don't
criticize is that scientific scholars
and scientists have always had in
international language it was Latin for
some time it was German yes and today
it's English it's true but Latin was a
dead language already I mean it isn't it
did not exist anymore in everyday
conversation so it was unmarked in the
linguistic sense of unmarked German
rained during a very short period of
time and today the reign of English is
not without passing some political
problems this is the reason why I am not
quite although I'm not reluctant non
loath to to adopt Roger I'm not quite
ready to adopt it without some
hesitation there is something imply
behind that which is
there's a huge
now I would have a question I think
you're not a journalist you are scholar
I say you I tell you why I opened the
question whether you might or might not
be a journalist I think this does not
apply to you but in general that there
is a kind of terrorist attitude when
repeating repeating repeating a thing
which which has not been demonstrated by
many observations I mean many people say
what you have just said to what extent
it is true is it true the ones who say
what you say have these people a
testimony of all the congress's in a
given subject in which they have been
able to observe that English was the
early used language and to what extent
is it not a journalist part to some
extent terrorist attitude the fact of
repeating repeating repeating that this
is the situation that you cannot avoid
it and that you have to submit yourself
to it to this I react
so to be a part but basically to publish
an especially well if it is true as you
say then don't you think that the ones
to whom English is not native and who
may be great scholars are in a situation
of an equality because they cannot
express their thoughtfully even though
you may per pro that physics is not a
literary matter and that you have just
two to expose what you have experience
about and to speak in terms of numbers
and so on there is also a certain
discourse in physic and this discourse
requires that you have a minimum
mastering of English and if you don't
this is an unequal situation of other
scholars who are not in your speakers
this is important question I thank you
very much
I'm not a good example I I think I think
it might
I am a is a if I can use this in the
origin a hyperbolized man and to the
extent they have hyperbolized I dunno I
feel at home in any language so I'm not
a good example I am some extent a
monster but Travie teratology big thing
about ordinary people the ones who are
very great scholars and who don't
express themselves in the part of their
talk which are literary discourse
linguistic discourse less necessary
disfavored as compared to the ones who
speak the native tongues were English
speakers that's right that's right this
is an interesting remark and when they
do it happened that they do also discuss
huge matters and their things which are
not just details what happens you know
you know I alluded to that in the course
of my talk that in the 18th and 19th
century many scholars in physics
chemistry and other let's just say
serious Sciences where polyglots they
were multilingual I mean the possibility
of scholars being able to speak the
language is not something which has not
existed it belongs to the past of Europe
and without saying that have an inner
stodgy erotica I was not born then
knowing that I think that this is an
example probably to be considered and
reflected upon the situation of today is
not quite unavoidable
that scientist has to learn five
languages for something somebody's just
true but this is no open to discussion
if we lament the death of language as
the loss of cultural system in a way of
thinking how much more richer might that
is let's try to you there that's right
I quite agree one last one
that's a language
every time I give a public talk if there
is an Esperantist somewhere which is not
your case probably well well I have an
answer I have an answer because this is
a question on which I have three even
strips driven to think as much as I can
and I must say the result of this
research is a great disappointment dr.
Simon Hoff when he invented he was a Jew
of the other stock in Polish in Poland
very occupied by the south David's are
like his white color Russians and it was
the majority of the population spoke
polish and the Jews who had the ghetto
spoke Yiddish and Hebrew in the dress
speak Hebrew that used it in the prayers
so dr. Sam who was an ophthalmologist as
you know an oculist generous man because
and of 19th century is a very
international internationalist period
he's he thought I will invent a language
in order to do he had the illusion that
a language can lead people to a
resolution of conflict was quite not
true as I said in the example Yugoslavia
and held other kind of illusion to trap
which were widely shared in there in the
end of 19th century so in he invented
Esperanto I think in in 1880 97 he
published his manifesto and in 1901 905
in Boulogne in France they had their
first Congress International which was a
success and then the contemporaneous
people who who lived there and who left
testimonies said that Esperanto
represented a great hope but now I give
you my opinion I think that there was no
impediment
there was no obstacle to the possibility
of a spread to becoming a real
international language all the more
since it did not have any political
power behind it since it was in
inventing language so the drawback which
I mentioned as as far as English is
concerned was not the case then however
my interpretation is this unfortunately
European countries were engaged in
fratricide cruel a new
when conflicts during less than 50 years
and in both occasions the massive
intervention on the United States make
American English what I call in
Esperanto de facto and this is my
interpretation in 1917 President Wilson
sent his troop relatively late but the
Americans came in the Second World War
the American intervention due to
Japanese attack was much sooner and in
both cases I think that the advance
of American English in Europe was the
faith the bad fate of Esperanto because
American English became itself what I
call this esperen to the factor and is
one of the reasons why I think the fate
of Esperanto is a sad one because human
stupidness and human cruelty where the
main obstacle to institution
[Applause]